[Music]  it's et social study a quick look at  what the stars are posting online I'm  grading back well this doesn't look too  good kaley cuoco  posted this shot of what appeared to be  a painful cupping treatment on her back  the actress captioned the pig hurts so  good  next Khloe Kardashian makes a statement  on International Women's Day flashing  major cleavage in a red hot dress with a  plunging neckline at the horse then  there's Rob Kardashian sharing a series  of precious pics of daughter dream  following his split from blac Chyna  while China continues to flaunt her  incredible post-baby body meanwhile  Beyonce's mom Tina Lawson is seeing a  strong resemblance between her daughter  and granddaughter Blue Ivy miss Tina  reposted a fan photo showing a younger  be next to five-year-old blue she wrote  in the caption Wow  so cute  you